вітаємо Ласкаво просимо до програми У
фокусі Європа Ми раді що ви приєдналися
до нас знищення дамби в Новій Каховці на
півдні України на початку цього місяця
стало черговим військовим злочином
Росією у війні проти України рівень води
в затоплених районах поволі спадає але
відновлення інфраструктури та розбирання
Завалів може зайняти місяці
крім того руйнування критично важливої
дамби викликало загрозу екологічної
катастрофи згідно з оцінками близько
мільйона людей не матимуть доступу до
прісної води
ситуація особлива загрозлива для усіх
похилого віку та з обмеженими
можливостями
для людей постраждалому районі це
чергова катастрофа у цій смертоносній
війні населення По обидва боки Дніпра
стикається з її наслідками
оскільки ця територія знаходиться на
лінії зіткнення існує додаткова
небезпека мінта вибухонебезпечних
предметів але навіть серед цих
випробувань є історій які мають щасливий
кінець як наприклад порятунок Максима та
його сім'ї які опинилися в пастці у
затопленому будинку
Що таке сім'я останнім часом Італії
доводиться розбиратися з цим питанням
правий уряд прем'єр-міністр-ки джорджей
malone ускладнює визнання батьківства
для одностатевих пар у своїй
передвиборчій кампанії Мелані вже
пообіцяла виступати проти сурогатного
материнства та усиновлення дітей
гомосексуальними парами крістіною
Джорджіо обурені цим Вони живуть у Римі
зі своїми доньками близнючками і тепер
непокояться за свою сім'ю
Настав час прайду в Римі і підготовка до
нього вже йде повним ходом женевра та
емануела а також їхні батьки Крістіну та
джорджу
вони одна сім'я вже 8 років і 8 років
вони разом ходять на парад
наші футболки видно в кадрі
Крістіану і Джорджіо були парою протягом
20 років після довгих роздумів вони
стали батьками у 2014 році завдяки
сурогатній матері у США юридичне
визнання таких сімей в Італії ускладнене
батьківські права спочатку отримує лише
біологічний батько в даному випадку
Крістіану
[музика]
єдиний спосіб для другого з батьків
статую офіційним батьком це подати заяву
на усиновлення дитини
але це займає багато часу і коштує
дорого
вони пройшли увесь цей процес і тепер
Джорджіо теж офіційно визнаний батьком
дітей але раніше Йому було нелегко
Одного разу я привів дітей до лікаря щоб
зробити щеплення а він відмовився робити
їм щеплення тому що я не був їхнім
біологічним батьком згідно з Законом Я
не мав батьківських прав
усиновлення тоді ще не відбулося тож
держава вважала мене сторонньою людиною
ситуація погіршилася після приходу до
влади прем'єр-міністр кі джорджі Мелані
та її ультраправої партії брати Італії
раніше У деяких містах дозволялося
описувати Імена двох мам або двох тат у
свідоцтва про народження але новий
міністр внутрішніх справ заборонив цю
практику тому цьогорічний парад має ще
більше значення для цієї сім'ї
Ми хочемо показати світу що ми нічим не
відрізняємося від інших сімей ми два
тато у яких двоє дітей така реальність
брать важливий тому що зараз коли багато
сімей скрутному становищі Ми повинні
показати нашу Солідарність і бути поруч
із ними
і ще одна небезпека для лгбтк +
спільного та в Італії парламент якої
обговорює закон що забороняє створювати
веселкові сім'ї від самого початку
в Італії вже існує заборона на сурогатне
материнство але незабаром можуть
заборонити і пошук сурогатних матерів за
кордоном законопроєкт представила
суратниця мелоні Кароліна варки
це
девіант перетворюють на рабин на об'єкти
які можна купити Це рабство третього
тисячоліття Ми впевнені що ця заборона
ефективна
тому ми хочемо розширити кримінальну
відповідальність щоб навіть ті хто
виїжджає за кордон були покарані щойно
вони повернуться до Італії
ми не здамося ми завжди будемо боротися
за права наших дітей
президентка асоціації райдужній сім'ї
вважає що влада просто намагається
розпалити ворожнечу проте одностатевих
пар
а в інтерв'ю перед тим як стати
прем'єр-міністркою Джорджем мелоні
сказала що райдужній сім'ї взагалі не
повинні вважатися сім'ями якщо хтось гей
він повинен жити з наслідками цього і не
заводити дітей
вона каже нам не ставати батькам і
робить усе можливе Щоб позбавити нас
такої можливості
[музика]
зараз в Італії йде культурна війна
навколо того що таке сім'я і як вона
повинна виглядати Крістіану і Джорджіо
не хочуть ховатися вони пишаються своєю
сім'єю із задоволенням говорить про це
публічної експресою
діти люблять парад для них це ніби
велика вечірка вони ще маленькі звісно
вони ще не все розуміють але вони
помітили що деякі люди кажуть що ми
зовсім не родина і це їх дратує вони
відповідають ми сім'я
і останнє опитування показують що
більшість італійців з цим погоджуються
Та все ж консервативна націоналістична
коаліція хоче просунути закон проти
сурогатного материнства цього літа І
вона має більшість у парламенті
культурна війна навколо того що таке
сім'я що далека від завершення
[музика]
зменшення споживання нафти і газу та
перехід на відновлювальні джерела
енергії Це виклик який зараз стоїть
перед більшістю європейських країн але
людям в Ісландії не доводиться стикатися
з тією проблемою Вони живуть на
найбільшому вулканічному острові у світі
тут завжди вдосталь геотермального тепла
і гаряча вода у надлишку фермери такі як
кнутор рафн-аурман також отримують зиск
від цього природного скарбу цей фермер
який вирощує помідори має джерело
гарячої води прямо на порозі свого
будинку навколо теплиць кнутора рафана
армана кипить сама Земля
геотермальне тепло підживлює гарячі
джерела Всього за кілька метрів вуглиб
за певну плату ісландські фермери можуть
використовувати природні енергетичні
ресурси цього вулканічного острова
звідси ми отримуємо близько 68 літрів на
секунду 90 градусної гарячої води для
теплиць
а також для будинків вдач ферм тут і в
околицях
мережа труб розводить гарячу воду по
теплицях кнутора підтримуючи постійно
яку температуру для його помідорів
він також використовує природні джерела
для поливу рослин
ти яку воду ми даємо рослини має ключове
значення тому що помідори на 92%
складаються з води тож я вважаю що для
отримання якісних помідорів потрібно
використовувати якісну воду
і в Ісландії вода дійсно дуже хорошої
якості вона надходить з наших гір
кнутор дуже пишається своєю екологічною
теплицею Він навіть отримує енергію для
ламп задля вирощування рослин із
відновлювальних джерел енергії дедалі
більше міжнародних гостей приїжджають
аби подивитися на його теплицю і
дізнатися з його презентації як ісландці
використовують свої енергетичні ресурси
і вони можуть скуштувати продукцію
фермерському ресторані оточеному
томатними плантаціями
його сусідка за кілька сотень метрів
звідси вирощує полуницю геотермальне
теплом можна використовувати для
створення оптимальних умов щоб вона
росла цілий рік
на фермі
гейс до тіре теж усе природньо
ми взагалі на оприскуємо рослини жодних
хімікатів ми використовуємо лише
біозахисники для рослин щоб запобігти
появі шкідників
свіжий фрукти та овочі на острові з
довгими холодними темними зимами
обходяться на дешево але фермерка яка
вирощує полуницю сподівається що в
майбутньому в ісландських теплицях
будуть вирощувати ще більше овочів і
фруктів
на всі люди готові купувати ісландську
продукцію бо вона дорожча але ми завжди
наголошуємо на здоров'я і на тому
наскільки корисні ісландські овочі та
полуниця
імпортна продукція в магазинах усе ще
дешевше якби на відносно дешева
геотермальна енергія вирощування овочів
та фруктів тут було б не прибутковим
ісландці здавна знали цінність своїх
гарячих джерел і гейзерів але не завжди
знали що з ними робити
людям це не дуже подобалося тому що
джерело було просто відкритим тварина
могли туди зайти і вони гинули тож це
було не дуже хорошем місцем але потім
десь у 1925 чи 26-му роках фермери
вирішили звести криницю Тож вони
забетонували джерело і тепер можуть
користуватися водою
[музика]
Отже у термальна енергія Ісландії
здається не дорогою та невичерпною
експерти застерігають від надмірного
споживання гарячої води із джерел вони
живляться переважно підземними водами і
на їхнє повторне наповнення можуть піти
десятиліття
думка про життя в Європейському місті
для багатьох звучить як мрія особливо в
місті настільки популярному що кожен
хоче побувати в ньому хоча б раз у житті
але для тих хто насправді там живе як
Ейс іпінг яку ми зустріли вамстердамі
популярність її міста перетворилася на
справжній кошмар
мільйони туристів приїжджають в
Амстердам щороку тусовочний туризм став
такою гострою проблемою в місті що
з'явились спеціальні таблички аби
туристи не пояснили і не заважали
місцевому населенню особливо вночі
це стосується не лише Амстердама багато
великих європейських міст стикаються з
цією проблемою і Амстердам здається
знайшов деякі рішення проте не всім вони
до вподоби
вечір п'ятниці 22:00 в Амстердамі у
кварталі Червоних ліхтарів ельс іпінг
хоче поговорити з тими Хто порушує
громадський порядок вона місцевий
жителька і більше не може терпіти
натовпи туристів
Це звичайний вечір вихідних Чим пізніше
тим галасливішими стають люди
вона натрапляє на групу туристів які
блокують вхід до будівлі
Знайдіть будь ласка інше місце де можна
присісти дякую вона хоче менше туристів
менше ніжного життя більше спокою і
більше правил у районі Червоних ліхтарів
це старовинний центр Амстердама Це
найкрасивіша частина міста із нього
зробили Діснейленд
ер з голими жінками за вікнами і
наркотуристами ми не можемо це терпіти
місто вже запровадило певні заходи щоб
взяти під контроль надмірний тусовочний
туризм зокрема розпочато кампанію
орієнтовано на британців із закликом
триматися подалі
також кажуть що бари і будинки розпусти
повинні закриватися раніше і що
заборонено куріння канабісу у кварталі
Червоних ліхтарів що на це кажуть
туристи Так Тут дуже людно напевно тут
навіть вікна не Можна відчинити бо дуже
шумно і пахне травою для мене Це
невелика проблема Але я думаю що для
більшості людей все інакше якщо ви
молоді і приїхали вам Амстердам то не
дуже добре якщо вони будуть зачинятися
раніше Якщо залишиться ще кілька
крамничок де можна буде покурити то все
тоді гаразд
важко не помітити такі ознаки в окрузі
очевидно що місто намагається
врегулювати ситуацію
але для тих хто заробляє на нічному
житті ситуація ускладнюється ця секс
працівниця хоче залишитися анонімною
вона каже що проблема у тому що будинки
розпусти зачиняються на три години
раніше ніж колись
ми втратили значну частину нашого доходу
і щоб компенсувати це більше дівчат
виходять на вулицю щоб знайти клієнтів і
привести їх сюди це дуже небезпечно
кілька років тому одну секс-працівницю
так сильно побили що вона досі в комі
вона каже що в будинках розпусти
безпечніше І що по п'ятницях і суботах
Там дійсно дуже людно але масовий туризм
- це проблема не лише Амстердама і ці
заборони допоможуть лише окремим
місцевим жителям
ці заходи були запроваджені для того щоб
місцеві жителі могли краще спати але ми
знаємо що через них люди які просто
легально роблять свою роботу наражаються
найбільшу небезпеку чи добре їм спиться
тепер
які більш раціональні заходи проти
масового туризму Можна було б
запропонувати фрік валах нічний мер
Амстердама який представляє різні нічні
спільноти І виступає посередником між
мешканцями і владою
Він вважає що місто обрало хибний шлях
запроваджуючи дрібні заборони і
ухиляються від очевидних заходів які є
необхідними
Ми повинні серйозно зайнятися
туристичною галуззю а саме дешевими
авіаперельотами це мало п сенсі для
навколишнього середовища тоді нам Не
доведеться руйнувати традиції та
спадщину Амстердама такі як ліберальна
політика що на канабісу та секс праці
повернімося до насиченого вечора
п’ятниці
раніше була членом Ради тому багато
людей тут знають її та її погляди
суспільні витрати на такий вид туризму
занадто високі
її перебуває жінка яка каже що має тут
бар
мене оскаржимося бо на цьому роблять
бізнес на цьому заробляють на життя я
розумію чому ви не скаржитеся але ви ж
не можете сказати ми не скаржимося бо не
гадимо в тарілку з якої їмо
місцеві жителі проти місцевих
підприємців конфлікт може навіть стати
особистим якого висновку дійшла ельс
іпінг
[музика]
агресивність по відношенню до мене і
можливо до інших зростає з боку
підприємців
я можу сприймати це як комплімент тому
що ми встановимо для них загрозу але все
ж це не дуже приємно
цього року Амстердам очікує понад 18
мільйонів туристів для когось це кошмар
для інших золота жила для міста дилема
дилема яку навряд чи вдасться вирішити
найближчим часом
ніхто не вчиться ефективно на порожній
шлунок але в Німеччині деякі Діти
відвідують школу навіть не поснідавши
хороша новина люди похилого віку в
країні об'єднали зусилля щоб змінити цю
ситуацію ці три жінки в німецькому
Дрездені щоранку дарують посмішку дітям
Дбаючи про те щоб вони починали свій
день із повноцінного сніданку
близько двох тисяч літніх людей роблять
цю добру справу у багатьох школах по
всій країні а на сьогодні це все
Бережіть себе і до зустрічі наступного
тижня
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив Київ 2023 рік
[музика]